if you're dating below okay you're  normally make him a project and you you  kind of a woman might want him they'll  see the vision of him being a bus driver  but really is a cleaner so they'll work  on that when really they should be  working on themselves  and that's the problem that I have with  that like I've got my goddaughter you  know she if I say to her oh she's now 34  34.  um I think you'll be suited to someone  who's 37. she thinks oh that's too much  of a big man and I'm thinking that's  ideal for you not the guy that you've  just you know left the guy that you're  not with who was kind of relatively your  age but you had to kind of work on him  to be the person that he is today yeah  that took a lot of working hard you know  like disappointment and now she's not  with him so at the end of the day for me  I actually want to meet someone at a  higher level